you can follow the travels of the two
c-span school buses and their schedules
at c-spanschoolbus.org
we're going to continue our discussion
about politics and about the presidency
kevin phillips is on your screen right
now and as i told you earlier the author
of numerous books his latest is called
american dynasty aristocracy fortune and
the politics of deceit in the house of
bush
what is your thesis in this book my
thesis is that we have had four
generations of the bush family in the
united states
two of them the most recent two were
presidents the previous one was a u.s
senator who wanted to be president and
the two great grandfathers of the
current president before that were the
ones who made the money
and the this dynasty is unique in the
sense not only the the mere eight years
between the two presidents who had the
same almost the same name they look a
lot alike they had the same interest
groups the same donors a lot of the same
voters and the four generations go back
and you find the family that has been
involved in finance in oil
in the early years and the middle years
and the current years of what eisenhower
called the military industrial complex
and with a thread running through it all
of closeness to the intelligence
community and as a result you have a
kind of unique pattern of how they have
ascended to power and also i think a
very unique set
of commitments and grudges and financial
interrelationships with people in parts
of the world that have posed some real
problems from the united states as we
get sucked in further and further to the
middle east how does this family history
differ from other political dynasties
such as the kennedys well the kennedys
had just one president they haven't yet
had two i doubt that they will the adams
has had two but they were in different
parties and 24 years apart so there's
hardly any continuity the roosevelts had
two but they were only cousins in
different parties and 20 years apart so
this whole pattern is much more
interrelated than the previous ones and
i think on every dimension
from enron and halliburton and energy to
saudi arabia and bin laden ties in iraq
you really have a continuity of interest
groups relationships tactics and grudges
between the 41st president and the 43rd
now as you mentioned that list um it
sounds a lot like many of the callers
that we have on the program who have
been following some of these stories and
you mentioned mr phillips in your
introduction that it's important in your
mind to distinguish between the
conspiracy theorists and genuine
research into this would you pick up on
that thought well obviously conspiracy
all you have to do say for example is
punch in
george bush and hitler on the internet
and he'll get about 12 000 citations
most of which are totally off the wall
conspiracy theorists are all over the
place in american politics but the
difference between
uh
investigation and conspiracy in terms of
dynasties is really very simple uh
europe and the history of a lot of the
monarchies over there i mean everybody
knows the dynasties in britain the
tudors the stewards the hanoverians
currently the house of windsor but they
all involve elements of conspiracy and
plotting and planning and favoritism to
get where they were because that's part
of how it works historically if you're
going to keep a family in power
not everything is above the surface it's
more like an iceberg where 10 percent is
above the surface and 90 has been going
on for a while but people don't know
about it that's not conspiracy theory
that's
proven history the way dynasties work
well speaking of uh the houses of europe
you do say that what you see is
happening in the united states with
dynastic policy is a trend that is
happening globally in the far east in
europe and as well would you talk more
about that well i wish it wasn't
happening but it is you can see that
from italy to eastern europe there's
some growing demand generally from
people in conservative politics to bring
back some of the monarchies that were
thrown out of different countries at the
end of world war ii generally for some
degree or rather a fascist connection
this has been the case in italy romania
bulgaria has a prime minister who was
also a claimant to the throne
the bush administration which is is no
stranger to some of these thought
processes uh has actually had different
points the idea of restoring the
monarchy in iraq and in afghanistan so
it's been mentioned in both countries
i find this extraordinary the period
really the 50 years after the end of
world war ii saw the end of a lot of
monarchies and what we've seen in the
last five years but the seeds go back
well into the late 80s and 90s is the
restoration of monarchies and to me the
parallel between the restoration of the
bushes in 2000 and the restoration of
some of the royal families after they'd
been overthrown and then kicked out of
paris in london and then they come back
10 or 15 years later it was called a
restoration i mean the restoration
comedies in in stuart england uh
a lot of the same sort of thing happened
in 2000 the most conservative part of
the country was leading the restoration
the south and you had a major element of
support from the religious leaders who
are almost always part of a conservative
restoration to me this this whole set of
parallels is a fascinating one but
americans aren't all that big on that
kind of history so it's kind of hard to
market it you write that what's at the
stage for this it was the uh reaction
first of all to losing the first bush
white house and then seeing especially
the the moral problems that might
erupted during the clinton
administration a real desire by
republican partisans to restore power
now
might the stage be set for the same
thing in 2004 as a result of florida and
the anger the democrats have about the
situation there well i suppose it might
one of the things i get into in the book
is the the notion of the october
surprise back in 1980
when the
some of the democrats claimed that the
republicans in the reagan bush campaign
were plotting with the revolutionary
government of iran to keep the hostages
and not let them be released before the
election which would have helped jimmy
carter
so if you take that which there's some
more circumstantial evidence for this
that's come out in the last 10 years if
you put that together with 2 000 you can
figure out how democrats could be
steaming and think they wanted a
restoration but if they don't get it in
2004 they might have a different
restoration in 2008 they can restore the
house of clinton because there's some
sense that
hillary would like to be a candidate so
i think this is percolating in the
american system and not the greatest
thing around
there you have a bit of kevin phillips
330 page thesis that is in american
dynasty it is also fully annotated in
the back all of his references and and
research for the book uh but we'd like
to have you involved in the conversation
so let's get to some of your telephone
calls we're going to begin with a call
from concord massachusetts kevin
phillips
we lost concord let's move on to
lakewood ohio go ahead please yes good
morning uh
i was uh i wanted to ask the gentleman
here a couple of questions uh you know
i've been kind of paying attention the
last
20 years or so
not really a democrat or republican
but i notice i see a lot of things to do
with the media you know
and all this concentration and
saturation of the media and how they run
well with these subjects like you know
the sodomy laws in texas when meanwhile
the vice president's sitting on the
nation's energy policy and we're paying
two dollars a gallon for gas and then i
hear where you know they're wanting to
make
reagan put him on mount rushmore
and he raised taxes about three times
and they said he gave this big tax cut
and he raised everybody's payroll taxes
and the same kind of thing is going on
now 20 years later but it's just like
it's so venomous now and it's so divided
so so much hatred going on i just like
to know if this sir
what do you think the connection is with
the media and the energy industry and
the big money and is there a line there
between all of us
well i've been a skeptic of the media's
role in politics for a long time going
back to the period when i was active in
republican politics i wrote a book that
came out in 1969 called the emerging
republican majority and i was very
conscious at the time and i think this
was true pretty much through the 70s
that the media took the liberal side and
didn't want to see the change that was
bringing the republicans to power and
were very aggressive during the
watergate period and so forth now i
think kind of the reverse has been
apparent in the last three or four years
uh maybe it's just 9 11 maybe they think
it's a patriotic duty to go along with
what the white house says or what the
department of defense says but i think
there has been a real weakness in the
coverage of what's going on in this
country by the the media and my book
touring and different call-ins and so
forth i've just been struck by how many
americans don't think they get the truth
from the media anymore and i have some
of the same sense that there's just
an apology for the status quo and that
reminds me of what i thought was there
in the late 60s when they were
apologizing for a liberal status quo
manassas virginia good morning
oh yes thank you um a question on to mr
phillips that i know you know you just
mentioned that you used to be involved
in
i guess more conservative republican
politics and i was just curious whether
this book is more
about
you know your rejection of conservative
politics or republican politics because
i've listened to you on
pacifica radio and those types of things
which is a ultra ultra left-wing radio
they're talking yearbook for their
fundraising and i'm wondering whether
this is more of a concern for
real reporting or whether it's primarily
a result of your
shift to
what i would call most radical left-wing
politics
well i'm not sure i want to agree with
the notion of shifting radical left-wing
politics
i get into
some of my my motivations for this in
the book in the preface
and i start out by saying that a lot of
my views of the bushes came from my
activity on the republican side uh
president nixon was not particularly a
fan of the father ronald reagan was
certainly not a fan and nancy reagan
just couldn't stand george bush senior
and then john connolly another
republican couldn't stand him ross perot
ran against him in 1992 john mccain ran
against his son in 2000
and all of these people have had a major
undercurrent and what the bush failure
is is coming out again now the the
morning paper showed that people's
willingness to believe in him is just
crumbling this happened to his father
back in in 1991 and 92 he'd gotten up to
89 job approval in uh the gulf war and
by the time he was beaten he got 37
percent of the vote the lowest for an
incumbent president since william howard
taft in 1912. unfortunately as i say
my underlying view of the bushes comes
out of a more populous conservative
republican politics my total disdain for
the current bush comes out of a
political status as an independent
because until the republican party can
de-bushify itself and regain some of its
integrity i'm going to be an independent
bradenton florida good morning
yes good morning uh
i've been watching uh c-span through the
the political process here and uh i seem
to be getting a headache uh
you know i really i'm a democrat
and i kind of just
figured i'd just go with democrat but
since i've been watching c-span and
getting involved in in politics
[Music]
i agree i just don't know what to
believe anymore
and uh
i feel like um i enjoy watching the show
but my question is that that book uh
on president bush um is that like facts
and is that a favorable book towards
bush or a negative thank you it's a
negative book towards bush but as susan
pointed out they're just endless
citations of where the information comes
from
at the white house says well they put
out some attacks on me privately they
haven't come to grips with anything
that's in there and i think frankly i
don't know how many republicans are
listening to this show but i wrote a
piece for the los angeles times that was
in there last sunday and i basically
said all across this country millions of
republicans have no idea of what this
family has been involved in for four
generations no idea how much of the
precedent for the lies in in iraq come
from the lies that led up to the gulf
war and were involved in iraq gate when
george bush senior was building up
saddam hussein and
bill sapphire a former republican white
house aide and columnist for the new
york times back in 1992 he wouldn't
support the father because of that
so all i can say is i have a negative
view of bush most of it reflects the
negative view i had as a republican but
the last four or five years reflect the
negative view i have of a son who's so
much like the rest of the bush dynasty
unfortunately let me engage a little bit
on the chapter that you write about how
far astray you feel we are from the
views of the founding fathers um
and how the government might might run
if you think about the founding fathers
you mentioned the adams family for
example which had two presidents in it
but they were
very wealthy americans and some
histories have them as having very
vested commercial interests in the
outcome of the revolution how far astray
have we fallen in and where do you see
that happening i have difficulty with
john adams having had too much of a
vested interest i wrote a book some
years back called the cousins wars which
was about
the continuity of certain aspects of
american and british history through the
anglo-american civil wars and john adams
was a middle-class pretty solid but no
more than that lawyer in boston he
wasn't part of the the merchant clans
who made a lot of money out of shipping
in the triangular trade in the caribbean
uh by the time john quincy adams became
president he might have had a little
more money but you couldn't call either
one of them
rich on the other hand you could say
boston did have vested interest
representing as a lawyer in boston a lot
of the people he knew would have been
very concerned about commerce but i i
think it can be taken too far to distill
the the views of the founding fathers
based on their their economics purely
and simply that was something that came
in during the new deal period this
debunking of the founding fathers
because of their alleged economic roles
and i think it's partly true but
substantially exaggerated then go to
your larger point how how does this
dynastic politics you see happening
today differ from the original vision
that the founders had well the founding
fathers obviously
if there was one thing that crystallized
them and they put it in the declaration
of independence it was getting rid of
george iii
now i can't imagine that they ever
thought we were going to have george the
first followed by george ii and if you
take george p the son of the governor of
florida i mean you might even have a
future george iii there the whole notion
that this country that was founded in a
democratic and republican smaller small
d reaction against the dynastic and
aristocratic politics of britain would
at this point be falling into very much
the same thing i think one of the paul
people uh
the people in the history books that we
all know the first three or four
presidents marlton new jersey good
morning good morning susan uh mr
phillips i have two questions uh
in the 2000 election what affected ross
perot
have on the bush re-election chances and
does barbara bush have any presidential
history in her family's past
well it wasn't the 2000 election where
ross perot had the effect on
bush reelection it was 1992
and he did divide the republican party
he was very andy bush he referred to the
elder bush as i'm quoting a rabbit
and he talked about how
george senior had had filled up iraq and
that he was there as saddam hussein was
built up and this was part of the
collapse of george bush senior in 1992.
now as far as barbara bush's history of
being uh
descended from presidents yes she her
family uh
father's name was pierce and they were
descendants of franklin pierce now
franklin pierce in the annals of
american history is not one of the the
leading lights he was what they called a
doe face he was a northern democrat who
supported the southern slave occupancy
in the period running up to the civil
war and one of the last things franklin
pierce was remembered for was leading an
andy lincoln rally in 1864 in new
hampshire barbara bush is a tough woman
i mean i think she would have been a lot
tougher than franklin pierce but it's no
great asset to be a descendant of
franklin pierce next telephone call is
from holt michigan good morning caller
yes susan i'm a first time caller i've
watched your show from the beginning
and i was i just had one quick question
to ask mr phillips
does he have any idea if kenway ever
spent the night in the lincoln bedroom i
know the republicans were so on to
clinton and who his overnight guest was
and there was a rumor going around
about penalties spending the night there
and i would like to know that please
thank you i don't know i don't know
whether ken lay ever spent the night
there i'd be interested in knowing the
whole history of the bush family
relationship with the bin ladens it goes
back to the 1970s they had plenty of
meetings in washington the bin ladens
were part of the carlisle group where
george bush senior was involved and they
flew them out right after 9 11. i've
never seen a history of
any bin laden spent any nights in the
white house i think it would be
interesting to see
somehow we ought to have a published
list of everybody who sleeps in the
lincoln bedroom be they democrat
republican or whatever
you write about the turning point at
which the um the the
george w bush was clearly going to be
the successor to george h.w bush rather
than jeb who had been
rising through republican politics would
you talk about that well 1994 what you
had was the george w won in texas when
his brother lost in florida now jeb had
been thought by
certainly the father and i think barbara
bush to some extent but maybe not
as as the better suited of the brothers
to politics
and but as soon as george w won in texas
in 1994 and jeb lost in florida then
george w had moved ahead and i think
frankly he was much more suited to the
restoration because he evoked his father
more and although his father left office
with a very low approval rating in
november of 92
as bill clinton did his thing
people sort of yearn for getting back to
what they thought was a better family
life with the bushes
so that by the time the 2000 election
rolled around the bush name and its sort
of little house on the prairie supposed
morality was a big plus and i think
george w looking more like his father
and having the same name was better
equipped but up until 1994 a lot of them
thought it would be jab earlier in the
program we talked with daniel cass a
writer for commentary magazine who has a
piece that's
that suggests that president bush is
defining conservatism that redefining
conservatism in his own brand
let me
use that as a platform to ask you
whether or not this
presence of the bush family in national
politics is driven by ideology and if so
what is it
well i think they're redefining
conservatism now i'm not so sure that
they're in an underlying way driven by
ideology although i think george w is to
some extent in the middle east and also
by religion but my sense of the bush is
redefining conservatism is very real and
the first thing i have in in the book is
a quote from dwight eisenhower in 1961
talking about the dangers from the
military industrial complex i can't
imagine he'd be happy with a lot of
what's going on at all when i wrote
another book that came out in 1990
called the politics of rich and poor it
was an attack on bush top one percent
economics the lead quote on the back of
the book jacket was from richard nixon
who had read the book knew what was in
it and and didn't mind the aspersions
cast on bush
so i have this sense that the republican
party has been defined in a way that as
far as i'm concerned is unacceptable
whether it's the uh the repudiation of
the eisenhower viewer the
military-industrial complex or the move
towards top one percent favoritism which
was contrary to nixon's economics or
even the uh the standoffishness of
ronald reagan towards the religious
right he was the only president to be
married to two different hollywood movie
stars it was daughter posed for playboy
and he didn't go to church he didn't get
sucked into this whole orbit that george
w has where the religious rights
sometimes seems to be in control of
policy i think it's all been redefined
absolutely next is roanoke virginia
hello good morning um
this is the first time call i want to
ask mr phillips if he is going to write
a book on the uh kennedy dynasty
if they elect another president i'll
certainly think about it i've never
voted for a kennedy in my life
what do you thought scholar
i was a democrat until
i saw bush's feet and ted kennedy
sitting there
squirming his face around and that
really
really i think
threw a stock in the uh american public
space which speech are you talking about
yes
uh state of the union just this last one
right so you just changed your party
affiliation about three weeks ago yes
because uh it seems like all the
democrats are doing now is dirty gutter
politics and they're talking about the
country being split i think they're the
ones that split in the country just to
get to be back on top since bush won
over gore
thanks for the call anything more for
her well politicians in both parties
tend to split the country i remember
back in the nixon administration we had
a term positive polarization
and the idea of positive polarization
was basically to accentuate the issues
that divided the opposition
and essentially that's
you know forcing people into a divided
and competitive mode and any serious
politician does this and i can
understand that a southern democrat
might say well i can't take the
democrats anymore a lot of northern
republicans in my neck of the woods
can't take the bush version anymore
a little item in today's new york times
intelligence panelists that the last two
have been named to the
the panel that's charged with looking
into the intelligence that was used to
justify the iraq war those will be
charles vest who has served as president
of mit since 1990 and henry rowland
professor emeritus of public policy at
stanford
i heard your commentary on npr this week
about the co-chairs of this which
includes chuck robb and lawrence
silberman why are you so angry
frustrated disapproving at the of the
choice
well i don't care much about chuck robb
and i don't think the white house does
either he's not going to rock anybody
the problem is with larry silberman now
in the course of all the research i did
for a couple of the chapters of american
dynasty i was quite familiar with the
the circumstances of both the iran
conference scandal and the october
surprise scandal so the minute i hear
that larry silberman who's a senior
appellate court judge an old-timer in
the republican party was selected to be
the republican co-chair of this i
immediately uh all kinds of lights start
flashing because larry silberman uh has
been mentioned very specifically in the
book firewall that larry walsh who was a
special prosecutor for iran contrary now
larry walsh was always very credible to
me because my father knew him and he was
a deputy attorney general republican in
the eisenhower administration and he
flat out criticized larry silverman as
having been on the periphery of the
october surprise meeting with
representatives of the iranian
government about the hostage's release
from the standpoint of not having them
released and then also specifically
walsh criticized silberman
for when he was on the appeals court in
in the washington dc circuit uh
basically going beyond any
semblance of judicial behavior in trying
to wipe out the the conviction of oliver
north and the iran contra affair and on
one of the pages of walsh's book he
talks about how he was almost going to
prepare a an argument that there was
judicial misconduct on silberman's part
and send it to the house judiciary
committee and i suppose that might have
been a prelude to trying to get him
impeached he didn't do it in the end but
anybody who wants to read about this get
a hold of larry walsh's book firewall
and look up lauren silverman that panel
also has john mccain who's gotten a lot
of press for his selection to that panel
what do you believe its ultimate outcome
will be with this makeup i don't think
that there's going to be much outcome at
all i think the principal outcome will
be that they get it all past the
election as far as the committee is
concerned but i don't think it will get
past the election as far as the public
and the opposition are concerned next
call for kevin phillips is from
minneapolis you're on the air good
morning i just had a question regarding
a
historical matter i wanted to find out
what your views were about the use of
the lincoln quote that you used on in
one of the books and how a number of
historians came out and said that it it
was untrue and and not a correct quote
um the second issue is
relating to the bush administration
and
how much of our domestic policy is
skewed by them one way or another i mean
we got a 2.4
trillion dollar flood federal budget
economists have picked out about 100
billion of going to corporate welfare
i'm not really seeing a very good link
between
uh let's say the wealthy in america one
percent getting 99 percent
of a benefit of a 2.4 trillion dollar
federal budget
when the the best economist can come up
with 100 billion last question was i was
wondering your position in the nixon
administration
well my position was very short-lived i
worked in the campaign and then i worked
as special assistant for the us attorney
general but after my book the emerging
republican majority came out i was
basically too hot to handle so i had
very little to do and they acquiesced
into me resigning and i went out to
become a commentator at that point on
the notion of the the unfairness of the
economic program i completely agree
everything i've looked into about the
bush's history is
the the four generations have always
been involved either in the financial
side of the oil business or investment
firms banking firms brokerage houses and
they have a total commitment to the top
one percent economically now the the
first part of the question i'm
trying to remember exactly what it was
uh
you know i didn't take a note i'm sorry
um let me move on to another topic for
you which is uh before you arrived i
told people several times that uh and
the next sunday this sunday you will be
number two on the new york times
hardcover nonfiction list and here it is
right here on the page uh price of
loyalty ron suskind is a number one spot
the new york times also reviewed your
book michael oreskis wrote the piece i
just wanted to have you to respond to
one thing he wrote which is a reader is
tempted to jake phillips and say aren't
we all products of our forebears
well i suppose so but we're not all
president
so i can dispose of that particular
quote easily enough when we've got a
family that's produced the last two
republican presidents only divided by a
democratic president i think we want to
spend some time looking into the
forebears but one of the fascinating
things about the bushes
is that before george senior was elected
president in 1988 there was only one
biography of him only one
inquiry into his family and that was
written by a former aide of his at the
united nations and it's just
extraordinary that you can preempt as
successfully as that i guess nobody else
figured it was worth writing a biography
of him there was one out there already
we got into the white house without any
basic screening and then of course he
just got absolutely clobbered in 1992 so
nobody bothered to go back again because
they all figured he's gone this time
around for uh president bush that you
were able to turn to a number of books
about him that have been written what do
you think are the best
well
one of the best is the biography that
came out in 1998 by herbert parman i
mean this was during a period where i
suppose you might have thought that
george w was in motion but it wasn't
devoted to george w was pretty good in
terms of cataloging things about george
senior he just didn't pick up on them uh
i like parmet he wrote a book about
nixon that i thought was one of the
better books about nixon but he's pretty
easy on
really on republican presidents there
was a book
that i think it was called marching in
place by dan goodgame and another time
writer that came out in 1992.
it was a very good book in the sense
that it really exposed the shallowness
of the the policy apparatus under george
senior but it came out at a time when he
was already sliding down the tubes so it
didn't get much attention because with
his velocity down the tube you didn't
need to add too much more
some of the recent books have been quite
good about george w but i haven't kept
up with every last one of those
next is a telephone call from texarkana
texas you're on kevin phillips good
morning i enjoy your program thank you
for
being a voice for the world
uh a real american leaders on this
program i'm learning democracy work i i
must read your book i have a question i
have three but i'll limit it can you
please explain a bit about the george
bush's uh now defunct bankrupt company
our booth osama bin laden's investment
in that company was he repaid um
when the company went bankrupt
were his funds frozen at any time and
was 9-1-1
involved as a type of revenge or
anything in this involvement and
if you could speak about skull and bones
i won't mention the arms market
arms merchants involvement in the world
let me try to get our bus though because
i don't think we can bite off two huge
chunks here but the arbusto thing you're
referring to this is george w bush's
first oil venture in texas in the late
1970s
now he raised money through a
a texas businessman named james bath who
according to some sources had been
recruited by his father as a cia asset
and beth
if he was recruited it was because he
was the north american representative of
the bin ladens and the bin mafu's family
who were saudi bankers now at this point
in time osama bin laden would have been
just a kid i mean there's no osama bin
laden problem here at all at that point
but it does show the closeness of the
bushes to the saudis and the saudi royal
family and the saudi money people
i don't believe that they ever really
got any serious money back from their
investment in in our busto because as a
lot of people pronounced it slightly
differently it was pretty effectively
and pretty quickly arbusto
so the bush then went on to a number of
other oil companies and they all have
sort of the same pattern as one of the
the british papers joked that every time
he drilled a dry hole somebody filled it
up with money for him so this pattern
went on and on and on but then you get
to the the 1990s and the bin laden
resurfaced as investors in the carlisle
group which was uh george senior by that
time out as president was a major uh
participant in the carlisle group he was
a member of its asian advisory group and
he was a rainmaker he went and raised
money now 12 families were recruited
from saudi arabia as investors in the
carlyle group we don't have any
information as to how much money was
involved uh
this crowd included the bin ladens and
the bin ladens were investors in the
carlisle group and and only ceased to be
investors i think after 9 11. and they
came to the united states for different
meetings and
bush was it some and jimmy baker the
former secretary of state and frank
carlucci reagan's secretary of defense
uh and then the bin ladens were flown
out everybody knows this but we don't
have all the details there were some bin
ladens flown out of the united states
right after 9 11. so i share some of the
concerns i wish we had something from
the media and i understand the 911 you
don't want to rock the boat but just
taking everything we know about the
connections between the bin ladens and
the bushes the meetings and the flights
and putting it all out there so people
just have the obvious truth and not
inflamed versions of it her last uh
point was also about skull and bones
would you like to talk about that well
skull and bones i mean that makes you
think of a cross between a pirate movie
and a halloween disguise and i don't
think it's too big a deal anymore
but one of the chapters in the book
talks about the uh the really critical
period for the bushes uh back in the
1920s and 30s and at this point in time
skull and bones was a big deal because
the people who've been part of the
groton harvard set who joined the good
clubs there for letter rebellion and
avril harriman was a major part of it
shifting the focus to yale and skull and
bones which was the
exclusive secret society and the people
that were in skull and bones were very
much involved in the the international
expansion of american finance in the 20s
and 30s after world war one so it was a
very important phenomenon but
it doesn't mean much anymore and i think
to exaggerate its importance today is a
mistake so if uh if we end up with a
presidential election where both both
candidates are members of skull and
bones you think that's not a point worth
dwelling on this year well the only
thing i'd add is a teresa hines i don't
know whether her husband john who went
to yale was in skull and bones but her
father-in-law h.j hein senior was in
skull and bones so you really got a kind
of multi-dimensional process here but no
i don't think it's too important anymore
prairie village kansas good morning to
you yes mr phillips i just think your
work is brilliant i've read several of
your books uh i think the point you made
earlier about the bush and reagan
involvement in iraq it should be really
thoroughly analyzed there's one book
robert d kaplan's the arabist which
talks about how saddam
tortured an american businessman pulled
out his toenails and fingernails and we
didn't do a darn thing about it we had a
mission in iraq at that time robert d
caplans the arabs there's a christian
science monitor article of july 7
1987 where they show how we supported uh
saddam in his war against iran
notwithstanding that iran was using
children as combatants and they have a
picture there of a little iranian child
soldier with its legs cut off
a third thing that just recently come
out i watch german tv daichi bella tv
here in johnson county kansas they had a
series our friend saddam and they
actually have a picture of rumsfeld
going up and shaking hands with saddam
it's not as still national security
archives have still of that kind of
coziness
and then i i just don't understand i
think you have considerable talent and
you should do a book about uh our venal
foreign policy in iraq and to protect
oil
and what the interesting thing at the
same time all this was going on
lieutenant colonel north was trying to
sell missiles i guess he did to iran so
we were both we're on both sides of that
war it's just it just and then when did
you know let me tell you because i think
you made the point thank you very much
well unfortunately i totally agree with
that that's uh a fair part of chapter
nine of the book but there's a book
that's specifically about all of this
build up called spiders web how the u.s
illegally armed iraq by a fellow named
alan friedman who was a correspondent
for the financial times of london who
wrote the definitive book
and he has in there
a mixture of
proof and circumstantial evidence
that saddam was getting the okay and he
was allowed to use the chemical weapons
that he got some of the nuclear
technology and his people were allowed
to attend a
nuclear forum that was put on by the the
u.s authorities in portland oregon so
yeah there were weapons of mass
destruction uh
in iraq by 1990 and 91 and
we know where they came from they came
from the united states that's where they
got their biological cultures that's
where they got a lot of their stuff and
this friedman book is a brilliant book
and it's just amazing to me that this is
just part of this
almost negligence by the major american
media
if uh the the us and george bush was the
part of the policy the first search
quest of supporting saddam hussein why
did he wage war against him in 1990 oh
well this is unfortunately another very
sad story uh essentially he was involved
in supplying saddam he he did this even
after the iran-iraq war ended in 1988
because in 1989 and 90 when he was
president he was convinced that saddam
hussein was becoming friendly to the
united states so you had this ongoing
supply now saddam had a lot of problems
in 1990 because after fighting the
iraqis iraq was fighting the iranians
iraq was bankrupt so the united states
was sympathetic to this and he needed to
get a lot of money he needed to get oil
revenues and the kuwaitis were siphoning
it's called slant drilling on their side
of the romania oil fields they were
drilling into iraq and taking oil out
so what saddam apparently wanted was to
be able to go in and nibble some of uh
kuwait's territory in the romania oil
fields and the bush people and it was
margaret tuttweiler who was jimmy
baker's spokeswoman spokeswoman and then
john kelly who was the assistant
secretary for the middle east made a
series of statements right before in the
10 weeks before saddam invaded kuwait
about how we had no requirement
by treaty or anything to defend kuwait
and that we had no question we weren't
concerned about the oil issue and we
weren't concerned about the oil fields
and ross perot in 1992 and one of the
debates basically said and he was
absolutely right george bush senior gave
saddam hussein the green light to nibble
at kuwait and george bush senior
i guess convinced saddam that hey you're
not going to see somebody like this all
the time so instead of going for the
bronze he went for the gold he grabbed
up kuwait
so after this after this george senior
has to figure out how he sells the
united states on this fight which was
very closely contested in the senate
before they had the vote
and he came up with
there was a testimony given by a
15-year-old girl to the human rights
caucus in congress and her name was
naira
she said that 312 premature babies had
been yanked out of incubators in kuwait
by the iraqis well it turns out that she
was the daughter of the uh
kuwaiti ambassador of the united states
it never happened this was promoted by
one of the pr firms in which bush's
former chief of staff was a senior
official and it was funded by about 11
million dollars from kuwait
so in terms of lies in the way that all
this happened
it's a horrible story and you want to
look at the context of the weapons of
mass destruction deception you go back
to george senior in the fall of 1990 and
instead of weapons of mass destruction
you had words of mass deception and i
just find the familial aspect of this
the dynastic aspect of this just
extraordinary our next phone call is
from prescott arizona you're on for
kevin phillips good morning susan and mr
phillips i applaud you for trying to
educate
the american people uh i wish the
americans would be americans and put our
constitution
ahead of democrat or republic
and the biggest fear that i have right
now is what this administration
is doing to our constitution two quick
examples
uh the ominous bill
when the congress house and the senate
turned down the overtime